dans le monde une ombre d un très grand
merci pour votre témoignage toutes les
informations utiles à retrouver sur
notre site internet pour venir en aide
aux populations indigènes merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi cette grande
interview est à retrouver sur notre site
rt franchement tva plus tard
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
252 millions d'euros c'est le montant de
l'aide d'urgence promise au liban de la
part de l'onuci et de la france une
quinzaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement se sont entretenus ce
dimanche par vidéoconférence pour
soutenir le pays du cèdre dans la rue la
colère ne faiblit pas nouvelle
manifestation aujourd'hui et nouveau
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
la menace d'une deuxième vague de kobe
19 plane sur la france pour tenter de
l'éviter
le port du mat que se généralise petit à
petit dans l'hexagone
de nombreuses villes imposée à partir de
demain il sera obligatoire dans
certaines zones fréquentées de paris et
d'île de france
en biélorussie alexandre loukachenko en
passe de briguer un sixième mandat
d'après les premières estimations le
président sortant arriverait en tête du
scrutin face à svetlana à tirano sky à
une opposante surprise novice en
politique
épouse d'un opposant emprisonné
d
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous trouvez
sur rt france la colère gronde toujours
au liban les manifestations
antigouvernementales se multiplient
depuis la double explosion à beyrouth
qui a fait plus de 6000 blessés 158
morts
aujourd'hui encore des heurts ont éclaté
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
aient les forces de l'ordre ont répondu
par des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes aux
projectiles lancés par des individus
cagoulés
hier des dizaines de milliers de
manifestants ont pris d'assaut plusieurs
ministères écoutez le témoignage de
certains d'entre eux mais c'est la
moindre des choses est très fier vous
savez la dévolution s'invite pas elle se
fait par le peuple le peuple a décidé de
prendre au ministère
donc il le fait actuellement certains
l'avaient cette économie celle à moins
de faire un petit mois de révolte
hélas après dix mois d'inconscience
totale de notre caste de mafiosa qui
nous mène jusqu'à présent nous affirmons
que ce régime est corrompu / des sectes
basé sur le pouvoir et la religion et
nous l'appelons également le régime de
la négligence au point de laisser des
substances explosives dans le port de
beyrouth qui pouvait exploser à
n'importe quel moment la communauté
internationale au chevet du liban une
quinzaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement se sont réunis aujourd'hui
par visioconférence à l'initiative de la
france et de l'onu objectif répondre aux
besoins de la population de beyrouth
les participants se sont engagés à
fournir une aide de 252 millions d'euros
au liban écoute emmanuel macron inquiets
a présenté l'aide déjà apporté par la
france au pays du cèdre
la france a d'ores et déjà organiser les
rotations aériennes
nous avons deux bateaux qui sont d'ores
et déjà partis plusieurs coopérations
privé importer des doctorants ces vies
qui partira dans les prochaines heures
avec des voyages je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont déjà organisé beaucoup
de réponses de court terme l'objectif
aujourd'hui est de faire vite avec
efficacité de coordonner notre aide sur
le terrain qu'elle aille le plus
efficacement possible à la population
libanaise cette offre d'assistance
inclut également un soutien à une
enquête impartiale crédible et
indépendante sur les causes de la
catastrophe du 4 août
c'est une demande forte et légitime du
peuple libanais c'est une question de
confiance et les moyens sont disponibles
et peuvent être mobilisées et je
remercie pour celles et ceux qui sauront
répondre aux demandes des autorités
libanaises
une catastrophe qui secoue la classe
politique libanaise on vient de
l'apprendre
le ministre de l'environnement annonce
sa démission c'était déjà le cas ce
matin de la ministre à de l'information
que je vous propose d'écouter
c'est le point de non retour
le peuple a faim l'économie s'effondre
la crise économique financière et
monétaire s'intensifie nos familles nos
enfants nos parents et nos amis sont
sans abri habité par le chagrin le
désespoir et la frustration en ce moment
décisif nous ne pouvons qu'avoir une
position patriotique honorable à leurs
côtés je m'excuse auprès du peuple
libanais de ne pas avoir été en mesure
de répondre à ses ambitions et
aspirations en raison des défis
difficiles auxquels nous avons été
confrontés puisque la réalité ne
correspond pas à notre ambition et après
l'énorme catastrophe due à l'explosion
de beyrouth qui a secoué la nation
blessés des coeurs et les esprits
par respect pour les hommes des martyrs
la douleur des blessés et disparus et
des sans abri en réponse aux peuples
exigent un changement j'annonce ma
démission du gouvernement souhaitant à
ma nation bien aimé le liban de
retrouver ses forces le plus tôt
possible et de marché bientôt sur le
chemin de l'unité de la stabilité de la
prospérité
vive le peuple et vive le liban dans la
foulée sélim sayegh a annoncé la
démission de son bloc parlementaire
kataeb composé de trois députés
vice-président du parti s'est exprimé
sur rt france tout à leur écoute et il
faut qu'il y ait la démission d'un tiers
du parlement et donc nous avons
considéré que notre action est une
amorce pour encourager d'autres
parlementaires ou d'autres blocs
parlementaires d'avancer vers ce chiffre
là nous avons bon espoir de voir le 1/3
du parlement démissionner quoi qu'il en
soit il nous faudrait aussi être avec
les gens dans la rue
ces gens qui refusent désormais de voir
des responsables politiques siégeant
dont l'une ou l'autre des instances
constitutionnelles et en même temps
revendiqué au clamée haut leur soutien
au mouvement populaire la rue demande de
plus en plus que l'acte de divorce entre
la classe politique et le peuple soit
prononcée et c'est aussi une autre
raison qui nous a poussés à être plus en
cohérence avec nos principes et donc de
d rester avec les gens dans la rue comme
ce fut le cas hier la classe dirigeante
devra rendre des comptes devant les
tribunaux selon amine issac ordinateurs
de la direction politique du bloc
national il était notre invité tout à
l'heure il s'agit d'un crime prémédité
l'ensemble de la classe politique les
députés ministres les trois présidents
des chefs des partis savait parfaitement
qu'il y avait ses explosifs au port et
ils n'ont absolument rien fait pour les
enlever de là ils ont le mépris du
peuple libanais et comme je vous le
disais c'est un acte c'est un meurtre
prémédité et ces gens là doivent être
punis pour avoir laissé ses explosifs là
où ils sont cinq mille appartements ont
été dévastés la moitié de la ville est
par terre des milliards sont partis en
fumée je suis simplement en collège je
suis en colère comme tous les citoyens
et je peux vous assurer que le cette
fois c'est la dernière que ce pouvoir va
tomber il est tombé moralement il ne
reste plus qu'à tomber physiquement
c'est une n'est plus qu'une question de
temps
un temps plus ou moins cool mais croyez
moi c'en est fini
cette fois les libanais ne vont pas
reculer ils vont retrouver leur liberté
qu'ils ont défendu bec et ongles quand
tous les envahisseurs qui soit si lien
ou israéliens ce n'est pas un peuple qui
baissent les bras nous finirons par nous
débarrasser de cette classe politique
faut-il craindre un regain de l'épidémie
de covile 19 en france des indicateurs
inquiète le taux d'incidence a franchi
la barre des 10 cas pour 100000
habitants considérée comme le seuil de
vigilance
une hausse de contamination qui entraîne
le nouvelles mesures sanitaires
la principale le port du masque en
extérieur à partir de demain il sera
obligatoire pour les plus de 11 ans dans
certaines zones très fréquentées de
paris et d'île de france une mesure déjà
appliquée dans plus de 1400 commune
shu
[Musique]
je recommande la plus grande vigilance
je recommanderais à chacun quand on ne
peut pas respecter les distances de
sécurité de mettre un masque par
précaution
[Musique]
à saint tropez effectivement aujourd'hui
avec le port du masque obligatoire dans
toutes les rues il est vrai que c'est
nécessaire pour se protéger pour
protéger les autres voilà il faut
peut-être accepter cette contrainte pour
peut-être éviter de retomber dans un
conflit demandant la rentrée
à la rentrée des vacances le nombre de
tests augmente d'environ 15% par semaine
le nombre de diagnostics l'ue augmente
d'environ 30% par semaine donc il faut
faire extrêmement attention en milieu
d'entreprise en ehpad
comme dans les réunions familiales ou
dans les milieux festifs dans les
restaurants sur la plage partout il faut
être vigilant
[Musique]
en fait je suis venu pour prendre un
rendez vous pour pouvoir faire
le test pcr vu que je compte voyager en
fait je pars dimanche à dublin
donc on pourrait être plus sereine
pendant mon voyage je préférais faire le
test avec ma fille avant de partir de 50
femmes d'âme thuram c'est la deuxième
fois que j'essaye
la première fois c'était début juillet
je crois mais je n'ai pas pu obtenir de
rendez-vous s'est donc vu qu'avec paris
plage ils font beaucoup de tests donc je
suis ici pour essayer
il est question aujourd'hui il faut pour
être testé dans la journée et avant le
résultat le lendemain il faut 12 heures
pendant résultats donc sur les tester le
matin pas voir le soir et j'en ai testé
le soin on peut l'avoir lendemain matin
tu as gagné la guerre faux les armes et
les armes aujourd'hui hélas ce sont les
tests les tests massif
[Musique]
écoutez l'analyse de bruno m'égare ban
chef du service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière
ces décisions de port du masque l'espace
ouvert adapté à la situation
épidémiologique sommes dans un certain
nombre d'endroits notamment dans les
villes balnéaires l'incidence nouveaux
cas de contamination
bon il paraît logique et une cellule aux
effets prennent ce type décision
néanmoins ces décisions de port
obligatoire du casque dans l'espace
public père resté limité zones les plus
à risque il ya densité importante de
personnes de touristes à la fois pour
rassurer la population et les touristes
commerçants et aussi peut-être réduire
le risque de sa vie alors le problème
évidemment c'est que avec le retour des
vacances et à la fin de l'été vers les
grandes métropoles
ce risque va se déplacer vers les
grandes villes doubiens sûr que des
grandes villes comme paris commence à
prendre des décisions de port
obligatoire du masque long des berges
aide et dans certaines rues il y a une
densité de population attendus à moins
d'un mois de la reprise
la rentrée scolaire se fera malgré tout
selon un protocole sanitaire alléger un
document de sept pages a été envoyé aux
équipes éducatives de la maternelle à
l'université sont les détails en images
[Musique]
non
un allègement des mesures sanitaires
dans les établissements scolaires qui
inquiète nicolas glières il est
enseignant et membre des styles rouge
le gouvernement est inconséquent et
incohérent on a quand même le virus qui
repart partout et pas seulement en
france d'ailleurs dans toute l'europe
des mesures sont prises par exemple
l'italie pour la rentrée a décidé de
créer 80 4000 postes et ça coûte 1
milliards aux contribuables italiens ils
donc fait ce choix là nous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait romu la réalité le russe
repart partout on remet on oblige à
remettre le masque compris dans la rue
dont énormément de communes le virus
circule
il nous explique que tout va être
tranquille où on allège les mesures
notamment à l'université où ce sont de
jeunes adultes qui clairement son compte
et menant et autres en maternelle et en
primaire où nous enlève le masque alors
que les enfants ne savent pas respecté
des gestes barrières et qu'ils sont
contaminants et qu'ils sont contaminés
il ya une grande inconséquence ce
gouvernement est complètement incohérent
moyens réservés aux premiers gestes
barrières mal des classes peut-être plus
allégée mais pourquoi il faut investir
or dans le plan de relance l'éducation
est complètement oublié comme d'habitude
excédé par les rodéos frais les
incivilités des habitants de palavas les
flots dans l'hérault ont manifesté ce
vendredi je cite contre la délinquance
la racaille et l'insécurité
ils ont demandé plus d'effectifs de
police pour lutter contre la hausse des
incivilités dans leur ville sur les
réseaux sociaux
plusieurs personnalités politiques dont
thierry mariani et marine le pen ont
soutenu à l'action les habitants
aux etats unis plus de 5 millions de cas
de contamination de kobe 19 ont été
recensés c'est le pays le plus durement
touché par la pandémie
la crise sanitaire a de nombreuses
répercussions économiques pour soutenir
les millions d'américains menacé par
menacer d'expulsion est frappé par le
chômage donald trump a dévoilé un
nouveau plan daide les locataires de la
maison blanche a signé quatre décrets
faute d'accord avec le congrès sur un
plan de relance économique donald trump
a choisi de le contourner avec ses
ordonnances
d'abord je gèle les charges salariales
pour les américains qui gagnent moins de
cent mille dollars par an dans quelques
instants je vais signer une directive
demandant au ministère des finances de
permettre aux employeurs de différer le
paiement de la part salariale de
l'employé de certaines charges
salariales deuxièmement je signe un
décret ordonnant aux ministères du
logement et de l'urbanisme au hhs et aux
cdc de s'assurer que le locataires et
les propriétaires puissent rester chez
eux donc je protège les gens contre
l'expulsion
j'agis pour fournir 400 dollars
supplémentaires ou plus par semaine et
des prestations élargies 400 $ ok donc
c'est généreux mais nous voulons prendre
soin de notre population
ce n'est pas de leur faute c'est celle
de la chine la guerre commerciale que
poursuit justement entre les etats-unis
et la chine cette semaine l'attention
c'est un peu plus accentuée avec le
dossier techtoc du nom du célèbre réseau
social
les détails avec théo combes rien ne va
plus entre washington et pékin cette
semaine vient de marquer une nouvelle
étape dans les dissensions
américano-chinoises un conflit latent
qui se globalise depuis plusieurs mois
en début de semaine c'est la volonté de
donald trump de bannir tik tok qui a mis
le feu aux poudres
cette application de partage de vidéos
très populaire parmi les adolescents est
accusé par la maison blanche de servir à
espionner les américains
la seule issue laissé pour que
l'application continue à être autorisée
aux états unis
et simple pour donald trump elle doit
être rachetée au moins en partie par une
entreprise américaine
j'ai fixé une date autour du 15
septembre après quoi
l'application tik tok fermera aux états
unis mais si quelqu'un que ce soit
microsoft ou quelqu'un d'autre l'achète
ce sera intéressant je dis que si
quelqu'un achète quel que soit le prix
cela va au propriétaire à savoir la
chine mais j'ai dit qu'une part
importante de ce prix devra revenir au
trésor américain des déclarations
considérées comme de l'intimidation par
pékin les entreprises concernées
exercent des activités commerciales aux
etats unis conformément aux principes du
marché aux règles internationales et
respectent les lois et réglementations
américaines sous prétexte de sécurité
nationale les états unis abuse
fréquemment de leurs pouvoirs étatiques
et s'en prennent de manière injustifiée
à des entreprises non américaines
il s'agit d'un acte d'agression flagrant
et la chine s'y oppose fermement
nous avons également remarqué que
récemment de nombreuses personnes aux
états unis et des personnes de tout
horizon au sein d'air communauté
internationale ont critiqué remis en
question la proche américaine autre
sujet de discorde
'l'annonce d'une visite du secrétaire
d'état à la santé américain alex hasard
à taïwan prochainement
cela fait 40 ans qu'une délégation
américaine d'un tel niveau ne s'était
rendu à taipei la capitale
un véritable affront pour l'empiré du
milieu qui considère l'île comme partie
intégrante de son territoire
la chine ne va pas les laisser faire
nous rejetons toute tentative de créer
une soi disant nouvelle guerre froide
car elle va à l'encontre des intérêts
fondamentaux des peuples chinois et
américain comme de la tendance mondiale
au développement et au progrès quiconque
essaie de lancer une nouvelle guerre
froide au 21e siècle sera du mauvais
côté de l'histoire et on se souviendra
de lui comme de celui qui aura gravement
perturbé la coopération internationale
des propos extrêmement forts qui ne
semble pas atteindre le locataire de la
maison blanche
pour preuve de nouvelles sanctions
américaines vient d'être annoncée
vendredi à l'encontre de
dirigeants hong kong et dont la chef de
l'exécutif car ilham
une décision qualifiée je cite de
barbares et grossière par la chine une
nouvelle salve de sanctions américaines
dont donald trump n'a pas tardé à se
vanter en pleine campagne présidentielle
la corée du nord ou si vous regardez
l'iran ils veulent tous passer
rapidement des accords avec nous l'iran
demeure dans vie de passer un accord
mais ils attendent de voir parce qu'il
préférait de loin le passé avec biden
parce que s'il passe un accord avec les
états unis si la chine passe un accord
avec les etats-unis avec bail de nos
commandes
il s'emparerait de notre pays la
dernière chose que la russie veut que la
chine veut et que l'iran veut c'est que
donald trump l'emportent
c'est dans ce contexte volcanique que
les négociations commerciales entre les
deux pays devraient reprendre le 15 août
prochain
écoutez toujours à ce sujet l'analyse de
xavier riches est professeur émérite de
sciences économiques et spécialiste de
la chine chez ohb c'est de montrer qu'il
est toujours axé sur une sorte de
politique de compte elle même de la
chine donc que ça fait partie de cela
l'autre chose ne s'ajoutent aux mesures
que le gouvernement américain il ya de
prendre le vis-à-vis de la chine
concernant par exemple les hautes
technologies
il ya tout un ensemble de mesures qui
sont appliquées par le gouvernement
américain pour essayer de contenir à la
fois la prépondérance chinoise dans la
région d'une part et aussi le
développement des technologies chinoises
ou c'est aussi une réaffirmation de la
présence américaine dans la région
et ça change un peu les choses
en biélorussie alexandre loukachenko en
passe de briguer un sixième mandat
d'après un sondage officiel en sortie
des bureaux de vote le président sortant
arriverait en tête du scrutin en face à
svetlana à tirano sky à une opposante
surprise novice en politique épouse d'un
opposant emprisonné
robin parisse et jordi démarrer elle est
la rivale surprise d'alexandre
loukachenko à la présidentielle
bélarusse sviatlana tirs à 9 ce qu'aia
représente un espoir de changement
son mari blogueurs et opposant
gouvernement actuel est arrêté fin mai
elle réclame alors sa libération et
décide de se présenter à la présidence
professeur d'anglais de formation elle a
réussi à faire émerger une opposition au
bélarus pour incarner une opposition
structurée unis vers la nature and of
sky à cet allié avec deux autres femmes
véronique atsem kahlo la compagne d'un
opposant en exil et maria kolesnikova la
directrice de campagne de victor babarit
qu un ancien banquier emprisonné alors
qu'il souhaitait se présenter est un
il se trouve que je suis dans cette
position est que les gens ont placée en
moi tous leurs espoirs
tous leurs désirs de changement il se
trouve que je suis la personnification
de ses espoirs pour la première fois
depuis 2001 les observateurs de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe
l'eau et ce ne seront pas présents faute
d'avoir été invité à temps le nombre
d'observateurs nationaux et lui réduit
officiellement pour cause d'épidémie de
coronavirus une situation qui fait
craindre des fraudes selon svetlana tirs
à 9 ce qu'aia nous ne pourrons pas
empêcher les fraudes
nous avons vu au cours des deux derniers
jours à quel point cette élection et
effrontée mans falsifiés il n'y a aucun
espoir qu'ils compteront les bulletins
honnêtement
soyons réalistes total et nadine morano
alexandre lukashenko à redoubler
d'efforts pour enrayer l'ascension de
svetlana tirs à 9 ce qu'aia dénonçant un
complot jouissons de la complicité du
kremlin pour le faire chuter ce vendredi
vladimir poutine a assuré son homologue
biélorusse qu'il ne cherchait pas le
déstabiliser avant la présidentielle
une volonté réaffirmée par la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe
[Musique]
d'une part je ne peux pas évaluer la
transparence des élections avant qu'elle
n'ait eu lieu
d'autre part il y a un groupe
d'observateurs venant de différents pays
qui ont pour seule mission d'évaluer
l'ensemble du processus électoral
enfin depuis des années la fédération de
russie avance au sein de l'oaci eux et
d'autres structures mondiales l'idée
qu'il serait bon d'élaborer notamment
dans le cadre de l'eau est ce un
ensemble de règles qui donnerait un
cadre pour estimer la façon dont des
élections doivent se dérouler du produit
de leur transparence à catorive d'abord
établi qu'à qui met d'habitude depuis 26
ans ce pays d'europe de l'est n'a connu
que la présidence d'alexandre
loukachenko
face aux allégations sur de possibles
fraudes la france l'allemagne la pologne
ont appelé le président sortant à
garantir un scrutin libre et équitable
avant de refermer ce journal sachez
qu'au niger huit personnes dont six
français ont été tués ce dimanche par
des hommes armés venus à moto
la taxe est déroulée dans la zone de
cours et qui abrite les derniers
troupeau de girafes d'afrique de l'ouest
la région est une vaste zone instable
située dans la zone 2-3 frontière entre
le niger le burkina faso et le mali elle
est devenue un repaire de djihadistes
sahéliens emmanuel macron s'est
entretenu au téléphone avec son
homologue nigérien mahamadou issoufou à
la suite de cette attaque
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus d'une demi
heure
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le grave incident du tiges entre une
frégate française et des navires de
combat tueur doit nous faire prendre
conscience de l'évolution inquiétante